hello and thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is alex liversage and i'm the uk
and ireland seahorse instrument
specialist
for the cell analysis division at
agilent and i'll be your host for this
the first in a series of presentations
throughout the day
before i introduce our first speaker
allow me to share a bit about agilent
and our products for cell
analysis agilent as a leader in life
sciences
is very focused on enabling our
customers to gain the insights they seek
our rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio enables deeper
more reliable insights across a variety
of cell analysis
applications where investigators and
drug developers
seek to understand dynamic cellular
environments and interactions
this is critically important in the
large and growing immuno oncology and
immunotherapy fields
so for example discovering safe potent
and persistent immune cell products
require a more comprehensive
understanding of cancer biology
and immune cell function to that end our
presenters today will speak specifically
to how our solutions
are being employed in that context
i'm pleased today to welcome dr pinchae
ho as our first presenter of the day
ping chai joins us today from the
university of lausanne in switzerland
and following his move there from yale
university in 2015
his group has expanded his interest in
immuno oncology
with the aim to establish a fundamental
understanding
on how tumor cells evade
immunosurveillance through their
metabolism
and how it's possible to reprogram the
metabolic machinery
of immune cells to improve improve
immunotherapy
in this presentation pinchae will
present data on regulatory t cells
and their substrate utilization within
the tumor micro environment
one last thing before i hand over to
pinch there will be a question and
answer
period immediately following this talk
and to help us to get through as many of
your questions as possible we would
encourage you to type in your questions
throughout pinchae's presentation with
that
i'll hand over the presentation to ping
hello everyone uh so it's my pleasure to
present
uh our work with you and hopefully you
can enjoy it and then uh
please also feel free to uh put your
question and i'll be happy to answer the
question
in the end of the talk okay so
so first of all uh i would like to
introduce uh
uh where my lab is actually we are in
lausanne so
it's part of switzerland the
french-speaking part so we are very
close to the
geneva and my lab is mainly focused on a
mini metabolism and also
how we can exploit the information we
have in immuno metabolism
for cancer immunotherapy and also
understand
also try to understand how tumor cells
can utilize
their regulation in the metabolic
process of immune cells
to formulate the formation of
immunosuppressive tumor micro
environment and today i will talk about
our new story
which just published recently about how
intratumor t-rex
can be targeted by the metabolic
intervention
this is my disclosure slide and
before i jump into the data about our
study i would like to give you some idea
about how we consider
a proper immune response against tumor
should be done
so actually if we want to have a very
effective anti-tumor immunity
we should consider that those
tumor-specific cdit cells for example
they need to get proper infiltration
into the tumor micro environment at the
same time
they also need to get proper activation
within the battlefield they have to
fight against those molecular cancer
cells
however this kind of actions will be
compromised by multiple
microenvironmental challenges as listed
here
the first one is metabolic restriction
and hypoxia
so based upon the study i did before and
also other group they did
in the past few years we already start
to appreciate that
the tumor micro environment can be
deprived for
different nutrients especially glucose
can be one of the representative
nutrient which is deprived
and this represents a major challenge
for the two tumor-specific diesel once
they enter to the tumor micro
environment because those two are
specific t
cells they still need to use those
nutrients
to support expansion activation and also
production of effector molecules and
hypoxia also can become a very
difficult micro environmental challenge
for those in infiltrating immune cells
and the other microenvironmental
challenge is poor tears t-cell
infiltration
and engagement of co-inhibitory signals
in the t-cells
so those microenvironmental challenges
actually can prevent
properties and filtration by
manipulating the vessel integrity
at the same time the presentation of the
expression of ptl1
in cancer cells and also other myeloid
cells and other coherent receptors
can also further dampen the anti-tumor
response of the t
cells in the tumor micro environment and
the third microenvironmental challenge
people can also appreciate is the
accumulation of immuno methylatory cells
in a
migraine and one of the major topic i
would like to talk today
is also this immunomodulatory cells
which is t-rex
so t-rex as well as myeloid direct
suppressor cells m2 macrophage antigenic
dendritic cells they play
different kinds of immunomodulatory
roles in the trigonometry environment
which can further support the formation
of immunosuppressive stages
of the tumors and they apparently
accumulate in a tumor microenvironment
through different mechanisms
and how to target those immune
modulatory cells become another very
important approach
to control or to boost our host
anti-tumor immunity
so i would like to move to the targets i
would like to cover today
regulatory t cells the actual regulatory
t cells represent a major immuno
immunomodulatory cells in our
immune system because they have
different
function to control the over activation
of our immune system for example
as listed here those regulatory t
cells they can control dendritic cell
macrophage phenotype
through different effector moleculars or
through the direct
lysis activity at the same time
regulatory t cells can
also control vassal and also t
cell behavior through other mechanisms
so i will not go through all the details
but i want to let you know the presence
of regulatory t-cells play a very
important role
to compromise ongoing inflammatory
response and also try to fine-tune
uh the actions of our immune system
so you can imagine that the presence of
regulatory t cells play a very important
role to prevent autoimmunity because
once we don't have those regulatory t
cells you will start to see overt
immune activation by modulating multiple
immune cells
however in tumor micro environment we
can see
tons of regulatory t-cells in the tumor
as i mentioned before
and this is a typical example so this is
a breast cancer standing
so the top side is the normal tissue
breast tissue
and the bottom part is the breast cancer
and you can see in the breast cancer in
the breast cancer
you see tons of the regulatory tissue
accumulate which is labeled
in the bronze because this is a flux p3
standing which is a marker enzyme
marker transcription factors uh control
regulatory t
cell formation stability and actually
their action
so this result has been shown uh in
multiple tumors
those tumor sections you can see tons of
regulations
accumulate which associated with poor
prognosis
and more immunosuppressive tumor micro
environment
so based on this information people
start to wonder maybe we should target
regulatory
t-cells to improve host anti-german
immune response because we can alleviate
those immunosuppressive features in the
treatment micro environment
however these type of treatments lead to
several
issues first of all the t-rex targeting
approach
will also induce systemic direct
depletion
which might induce autoimmunity
in addition the direct cutting approach
so far
for the tumor micro for the intra-tumor
t-rex is not as effective as we
initially think so based upon this
information we realized that
actually there's a very strong need to
identify therapeutic intervention or
therapeutic
strategy which can allow us to target
intra-tumor t-rex while keeping tracking
other peripheral tissue intact
because in this case we can avoid all
the side effects you observe in those
direct targeting approach
so what people use
so when we start to come up with this
idea we start to
wonder whether we can put metabolism as
a part of this
therapeutic targeting approach and the
reason we have this kind of crazy and
also interesting idea because
we realized that regulatory t-cell can
reside in multiple
uh tissue or organs as illustrated here
so you can find regulatory t-cells not
only in the lymph node you also can find
that in brain in muscle and skin adipose
tissue gut
and spleen and they actually exert
distinct tissue dependent suppressive
activity or
tissue context dependent um
activity to control tissue homeostasis
so based upon this information we start
to wonder there must be something which
can control regulatory tissue behavior
in a tissue contact specific manner
so when we consider the entire
distribution we realize that
those place they have different nutrient
availability
and those cells in different organs can
also produce different west
and also preferentially spare certain
nutrient in the environment
so if i'm a t-rex i go to a place if in
order to survive
i need to get something i can eat
in a particular location so that's why
we wonder maybe t-rex behave
like that they would change their
nutrient preference
based upon where they leave if this is
the case in the tumor micro environment
this is the lack in which glucose might
be the private place
with a lot of hypoxia and also lipid in
rich condition
those regulated t-cells might engage
specific metabolic machinery which allow
them to survive
and even uh promotes their suppressed
activity in a tumor micro environment
and this kind of metabolic process
will not be used by t-rex residing in
other place
so we call this process metabolic at the
patient
so our hypothesis was very simple do
t-rex
engage metabolic adaptation in response
to the micro-environmental cue in
different tissue
if this is true maybe we can fight this
special
metabolic adaptation used by intra-tumor
t-rex
and then secondly destroy this
intra-tumor t-rex
by intervening this adaptation
so based upon this idea we first analyze
whether we can see this phenotype and
this metabolic skewing
in human samples so we decided to
re-analyze the rna sequencing data done
by sacha ludensky published in
immunity in 2016. in this paper
sasha they did analysis by collecting
t-reg from breast cancer patients and
also the pbmc
they perform rna sequencing in this
study they focus on chemotherapy
receptors
but by re-analyzing this data we pay
extra attention on the metabolic
machinery which should be used by
intro tumor t-rex but not in the pbmct
racks
surprisingly we found that
majority of metabolic pathways which
will be selectively
engaged by intra-tumor t-rex from these
breast cancer patients samples
is lipid metabolism so you can see on
the left hand side
lip metabolic process lipid response
type binding
those genes are highly expressed by
intra-tumor t-rex
in this breast cancer patient cohort and
the right-hand side is the ginseng
enrichment analysis you can further
appreciate that
the fatty acid metabolic process and
also lipid binding
gene set are highly enriched in tumor
t-rex compared with bbmc t-rex
so based on this information we start to
wonder maybe
intratube materials will engage unique
lipid metabolism to support
the survival and function in the tumor
micro
environment in this analysis we also
focus on
lipid transporter because if this is the
tr if this is true
t-rex might produce liquid by themselves
or
get lipid from outside and when we did
this analysis we realized that there's
only one lipid transporter can be
significantly increased by intra-tumor
t-rex
which is cd36 at the same time we also
see upper regulation of fabp4 m5
which is the lipid chaperone help those
cells to a store and traffic
lipid in the in in intracellular
compartment
so based on this information we first
confirmed whether cd 36 protein
expression level indeed increase in
intra tumor t-rex
in addition to the rna sequencing
analysis
we reanalyzed from the breast cancer
patient samples
so what we did was very simple we used
the tumor in graftman system we in graph
wire-type b6 mice with melanoma cells
18 days later we isolate t-rec from
different locations and check their cd
statistics
expression as well as lipid content and
lipid uptake
and here you see is the cd36 standing so
that
this is straining inferno and also
non-draining venom and we also compare
spleen cymbal skin and tumor
we observe robust increase of cd36
expression in t-rex isolated from
tumor compared with t-rex from other
place
in addition we also can see this
phenotype
if we analyze melanoma patient samples
and the left hand side here is the
representative facts plot and right hand
side
as i show you here each line indicates
it's a pair sample
so the white dot is the t-rack in pbmc
and the black one is t-rex in tumor
infiltrate
in a in a tumor micro environment so
compare
uh the cd statistics expression between
these two samples from the same patient
we can see that majority of patients we
analyze of melanoma patients they have
increased cd36 expression in intra-tumor
t-rex
which is also holding through it in
mouse model
so with this information we start to
believe
intra-tumor t-rex may preferentially
engage a cd 36-dependent
metabolic reprogramming to support the
accumulation
in the tumor micro environment as i told
you cd36 is a liquid translocase
so based on this information we further
test where the lipid content and lipid
uptake also increase
and indeed they also in those
introductive
also increase the elliptic content and
olympic uptake
compared with the t ranking pbmc and
also pt ranking out of place if we use
mouse model
so with this information we decided to
take a look when the cd statistics
indeed control this entire process
so we generate a t-rex specific cd36
knockout by
closing cd36 flux flux mines with flux
p3 yfp3
in this case the yfp3
expression will drive a t-rex specific
cd36 knockout
since i told you fox p3 is the key
transforming factors to control t-rex
differentiation
so in this case we can generate a t-rex
specific knockout and we use the
phosphate 3yp cream mice as a wire-type
recipient
for the following tests and what we did
was very simple we first in
graft melanoma cells which is a brav
v600 mutation with p10 with p10 deletion
and we engrave the same amount of
extensor cells into either wire-type
mice or
t-rex specific cd36 knockout
and after 18 days we isolate t-rex from
tumor and other
organs including spleen lymph node and
also blood
and we first confirmed that only
intra-tumor t-rex
from cd36 naga reduced lipid content and
lipid uptake
so this is lipid content and this is
lipid uptake and this reduction
can only be can only be seen in the
intra tumor t-rex because in
spleen in draining lymph node
non-draining inferno and also blood
those t-rex have very similar lipid
uptake and liquid by the uh and also
lipid content
between white type and naca so this
result further suggests that
intra-tumor t-rex selectively increase
cd36
and the presence of cd36 in those intro
tumor t-rex
support the lipid uptake and lipid
content in those intratuber t-rex
in addition to the functional test we
also observed that
those tumors engrafted in the t-rex
specific cd36 knockout mice
have slower gross kinetics and in the
end of the experiments
the tumor weight is also much lower
compared with wildcat mice
when we just knock out one single gene
in t-rex cells so this results further
prompt
us to take a look what happened why
infra tumor t-rex which can express cd36
will lead to this entire anti-trauma
response become stronger
so we take a look to see the t-rex
abundance
by analyzing the fox p3yp signal
in splenoside joining lymph node
t cells and also the tumor infiltrating
lymphocyte
by comparing those uh population we
didn't see any difference in terms of
the t-rex abundance
between y-type and knockout in spleen
and draining inferno however we start to
see 40
reduction of t-rex abundance in
cd-36 naka when we analyze the tumor
infiltrating
t-rex so this research suggests that
only intra-tumor t-rex needs cd36 once
we delete cd-36 in t-rex
you will start to see less intratumor
t-rex accumulation
but you didn't abolish the formation
and retention of t-rex in other
peripheral lymph nodes
with this information we start to
believe that maybe targeting city
statistics can be a good strategy
to destroy intra-tumor t-rex while
keeping the t-rex in other place
intact however abundance is only
abundance
we cannot guarantee those t-rex you
observe here
they still they don't express cd36 in
lymphanol or in spleen they still
function as a normal t-rex to suppress
the immune response
so in order to examine whether those
t-rex in peripheral tissue
they can still suppress the ongoing
environmental response
we did few tests and this is one of the
tests we did
we do that we did a t-cell transfer
colitis system
in this case we can transfer an icd-4
t-cell into rag-1 knockout
once we transfer an icd-4-t-cell into
regular knockout due to the lymphopenia
condition in regular knockout cd4 tc
will start to expand
and this expansion will lead to
activation of t
cells and they will also drive gut
inflammatory response so you will start
to see the ibd
syndrome and then they also start to
reduce their body weight
so as you can see here when we transfer
nice cd4 t cell the body weight of those
mice
reduce and this can be prevented if we
cold transfer
wild type t-rex or when we co-transfer
those naive c d for t-cells
we see the 36 knock-out t-rex and this
can be further exams
by checking the macroscopic
phenotype of gut colon and also small
intestine
as you can see here once we transfer
nicely for testosterone along
you start to see the immune infiltration
and the colon and small intestine lose
their morphology
but this can be prevented we call
transfer nicely cd40 with wi-type direct
over
cd36 narcotrex so this reset suggests
that cd36 expression
is is not important for those peripheral
t-rex they still can exert
information suppressive actions to
prevent ongoing inflammatory response in
gut in this t-cell
transfer colitis system and due to the
time
i didn't show you i want to show you the
data about other answers we did but
basically we also
checked the body weight loss in the age
mines we didn't see any difference
between wi-type and narcotics
and we also checked the t-cell expansion
and activation profile in the h mice and
we
we also didn't see any difference and
morphology of those mice in the major
oven they are also the same so basically
our data suggests that those t-rack in
peripheral tissue
they don't need cd statistics but it
looks like
intra-tumor t-rex they require cd 36
expression
to support their maintenance so based
upon this information we decided to move
into the next one
try to understand why in consumer t-rex
they can
they need cd36 to make to support their
maintenance
so we isolate uh intratumor t-rex from
wild-type mice
uh and also cd36
t-rex specific nakamites so from those
remaining viable intra-tumor t-rex
we can see based on rna sequencing data
those intra-tumor t-rex which don't
express cd statistics they start to
increase the expression of genes
associated with apoptosis pathway
as you can see on this on the left hand
side of this slide
so based on this information we we
realized that maybe
the deficiency of cd36 can drive
apoptosis in the intratumor t-rex
so we use two different methods to
confirm that so we did the active cast
test three standing
and also checked a next in phi standing
in those
remaining intratumor t-rex
in uh between wide type and also cd36
knockout
so in this analysis we found that
t-rex specific cd36 naka mice they have
higher level of intra-tumor t-rex
display
active cast pass-through staining and
also a
higher level of next invite stain so
this results suggest that
without cd36 we start to reduce 40
percent of intra-tumor t-rex but the
remaining 60
they are dying so with this information
we start to wonder
why this lipid transporter can do that
how this
lipid transporter expressed by t-rex can
come through the survival of t-cells
especially in the regulatory piece of
compartment
so in order to answer this question we
did
many different tests but none of them
works until we
perform electron microscope to
take a look what kind of changes we can
observe in those t cells
which in which they they don't express
cd 36
so as you can see here on the left hand
side this is the electron microscopy
analysis
so this is why i type my intro wi-type
t-rex
isolate from spleen versus cd-36
t-rex isolate from split we didn't
observe any difference in terms of their
appearance in terms of mitochondria
content and also the
morphology however once we isolate those
t-rex from tumor we start to see
huge difference as you can see here in
the bottom part of this slide
those wire type interactivity right
contain a lot of mitochondria but
cd36 deficient in tumor t-rex reduce the
mitochondria content
and also start to lose the mitochondria
structure
especially the three-stage number
reduced
and the right-hand side is the
quantification result so basically
this result indicates that the
expression of this leaflet transporter
is important to maintain the
mitochondrial content and also the
quality of mitochondria
in intra-tumor t-rex
in addition when we perform the essay
with the in vitro
culture assay we also start to see some
interesting phenotype
as you can see here so we generate those
id back from wire type or cd36 knockout
and we culture them
in a normal culture medium rpmi or rpmi
plus hypoxia which to mimic
one of the microenvironmental stress you
can observe in the tumor micro
environment
and the other one is that we culture
those t-rex
in the presence of cancer cell
conditional media
in both hypoxia and cancer cell
conditional medium we start to see
cd36 deficient t-rex reduce the
viability
and based upon this analysis we start to
postulate maybe
some common factors between hypoxia and
also cancer cell conditional meeting
can induce cell deaths in those cd 36
deficient
t-rex so the major common factors
in these two conditions is lactic acid
because in hypoxic conditions cell will
generate a lot of lactic acid and cancer
cell conditional media also contain high
number
high amount of lactic acid due to the
aerobic glycolysis activity of cancer
cells
so with this information we start to
take a look where the lactic acid can
really drive this difference in the
viability
so we cultured t-rex from wire type and
cities and cd-36 nacao mice in the rpmi
conditional medium
up in like medium normal median with
escalating those
dose of lactic acid and we start to see
the survival
difference between those two
t-rex so the cd-36 naka
t-rex reduce their survival once we
increase the lactic acid level
in the medium so this research suggests
that they need
cd 36 to deal with the lactic acid
enrichment condition which is pretty
common in the tumor micro
environment and you may wonder
what's the link between lactic acid and
also the mitochondria phenotype i
told you before so we also initially
think this is something quite
interesting and also difficult to be
explained
but once we take a look of the bio
chemistry textbook we realized that
actually
everything makes sense so
please follow with me i think this is
something i think it's interesting and
also makes sense if you
have the basic understanding of the
lactate utilization you will realize
that so
if we culture cells in a lactic acid in
rich condition cell will die due to the
acidosis and due to the high lactic acid
enrichment
microenvironment or in the media which
is quite common if we culture cells
in the same cultural medium too long and
we forget to change the medium our cell
will die for that
the main reason is that cell if we have
a lot of lactic acid in
extracellular compartment loss lactic
acid can
get into the cell or they will stay in
the cells if those cells produce lactic
acid because they will not
they will not be pumped out based upon
the lactic
gradient so those lactic acid stay in
the cytoplasm will become toxic
however t-rex they are pretty efficient
to
reduce the toxicity of lactic acid by
converting lactic acid into pyruvates at
least has been reported
in a cell metabolism paper published
last year
so in this study they showed that fox p3
can support this metabolic program to
allow t-rex convert lactic acid into
pyruvate
and this can make t-rex to use lactic
acid as a nutrient source
and this process can also make t-rex to
survive in a lactic acid
in rich condition however in order to
engage this metabolic conversion
cells will convert their led into nadh
so now it becomes very simple if a cell
stay in a lactic acid or lactate in rich
conditions like tumor micro environment
they will continuously utilize this
pathway and generate a lot of led
eventually you run out your nad pool
and this becomes a problem because you
need to constantly
have an id to help you to deal with lost
lactate
so in this case the mitochondria
activity becomes super important because
our
electron transport chain complex one
which can support the nadh
led regeneration by dehydrogenate
the nadh and this can provide
the cycling of nad and the action of
this process
will become super important for t-rex if
they want to continuously
utilize lactate and convert lactate into
pyduvate
so best quantity information we
postulate
in cd-36 deficient t-rex they lose the
mitochondrial activity
and this will abolish their ability to
generally generate nad
in a lactate in rich condition and
that's why they will start to die
due to the high lactic acid enrichment
so in order to confirm that we first
take a look whether the nadh and led
ratio indeed change
between wire type or track we allow cd36
expression as you can see here those
cd36 diffusion t-rex they start to
increase the nadh level so this results
suggest that they have the difficulty
to regenerate led to maintain the
balance of
an idea nadh ratio and we also
re-perform
experiments as i showed you before we
culture those t-rex
in a cancer cell conditional medium we
start to see the reduction of the
survival of those t-rex
however this reduction can be reduced
if we supply ribosome
which can which is a precursor of nad
can make those cells
generate energies throughout the
mechanism so in this case if we resupply
nad level
we will be able to save those t-rex
which which does
which do not express cd statistics so
based on this information we postulate
the reason infrastructure needs cd36
because they want to maintain
this mitochondrial action intact which
allow them to survive
in electric electric acid in reach to
the micro environment
and you may wonder what's the reason and
how cd36 can control mitochondria
phenotype
so when we look into the old literature
related to metabolic tissues we realize
that
actually cd36 has been reported
to support the lipid uptake and those
lipids actually can be used
as a ligand to activate ppar pathway
which is important to drive
mitochondrial biogenesis and
mitochondria activity
so we decided to take a look whether the
intratumor team indeed have this chance
to
increase their ppr signaling cascade
activity
so we take a look for the ginseng
enrichment in the breast cancer patient
again
in this analysis we see that those
breast cancer patients their intra tumor
t
react have higher expression level of
pbr signaling cascade
gene set compared with pbmc t-rex so
this results suggests that introducing
material
can display enhanced ppr bit ppi
signature
so we try to find which pplr is the key
player to control this process
so we generate ppr beta knockout and
also pvr gamma knockout
so for the sake of the time i want to
show you the gamma data but gamma
actually didn't change
anything so we didn't see any defect if
those t-rex can express ppr gamma
however if we use t-rex specific ppr
beta knockout
we can see the same phenotype as cd36
narcot
display including reduced tumor growth
rate
german burden and also the intra-tumor
t-rex number decrease
in those t-rex which can express cdr in
those mice which
can express ppr beta in t-rex
and pbr beta has been shown to control
the mitochondrial biogenesis and
mitochondria activity
so with this information we suspect that
actually cd36 can control the activity
of ppr beta
therefore it can support mitochondrial
fitness
and those t-rex ability to utilize
lactic acid
to confirm that we decided to take an
other exp we decided to perform another
experiment to
establish this cultural role so he what
we did was very simple
if cd36 helped the activation of pvr
beta
in principle we should resolute the cd
36 deficient mice phenotype
by artificially activating pbs data
so what we did was that we treated those
mice white mice or
t-rex specific cd-36 nacho mice with pvr
beta algorithms
so as you can see here the black rest of
the red so we see the tumor burden
tumor growth rate reduced in those mice
which don't express city statistics
in t-rex but once we inject
ppl beta agonist we can restore the
tumor growth
in cd36 nagal mice at the same time
we also we we also restore the
intra-tumor t-rex abundance in the city
36
knockout mice when we treat those mice
with ppr beta atleast
and we can also reduce the active
caspase-3 standing
in those t-rex which don't express cd36
so overall best foundation information
would propose a model
in a tumor micro environment for some
reason intra-tumor t-rex have to
engage this unique metabolic adaptation
in which the upper regulated cd36
which can help them to activate ppr beta
and this will allow
those intro tumor t-react to sustain
mitochondria activity to engage
mitochondrial biogenesis and stronger
mitochondria activity to recycle nad
from nadh and this will become a very
important action because in the tumor
microenvironment which is selected
in reached condition loss lactate will
continuously
become pyruvates if those t-rex can
still engage this process
however if we target cd 36 we will
abolish the cd36 ppr beta signaling
and then abolish the mitochondrial
thickness in those intra-tumor t-rex
which will make those t-rex died because
they take those lactate they cannot
convert
loss lactate into pi duvet they will die
based upon what they used to be very
good to do
so with this information we start to
believe that targeting this pathway may
allow us to selectly
destroy introduce while keeping the
debugging other peripheral tissues
intact
so with this information we decided to
take a look whether we can find
any metabolic intervention which allowed
us to target this pathway
and luckily we find that actually cd36
antibiotic which can bind the lipid
binding site of the
mouse cd36 can also induce the same
anti-tumor response as we see in the
genetic mass model
so when we inject this antibody to block
cd36 mediated lipid binding
we reduce the tumor burden we also
selectively suppress the intra-tumor
t-rex accumulation while
the t-rex in spleen and t-rex and drain
inferno they are identical between pbs
treatments or cd36 antibody treated
group
importantly those in draw tumor
remaining in transtumor t-rex
from the cd-36 antibody injected group
they also increase
active test pass-through standing so it
suggests that this antibody indeed
drive intra-tumor t-rex apoptosis
and when we combine when we do the
treatment with this antibody we see a
very
we see a pretty good anti-tumor response
which is quite
which is already quite promising
especially we do the same we do the
treatments only
every three days with a very low dose
but once we combine the anti-cd36
antibody with pd1
blockade treatments we basically
stabilize the brain inducible menorah
system
which is a system don't respond to pd-1
blockade
so with this information we start to
believe that we can use this approach as
a new
immune checkpoint blockade treatment but
this time we target a metabolic
checkpoint
in intra-tumor t-rex so we can use this
approach
to reprogram the tumor micro environment
to selectively destroy
disrupt or disrupt infra tumor t-rex and
this may serve as a new type of
immunotherapy
which we might pursue in a clinical
trial
and also in patients with different
tumor models with different tumor
so in the end i would like to thank my
people especially my students who did
the majority of this work
hyping and she just defend her thesis
and start her prosta
in a microbiota field and also my
another student who also helped us
on finalizing the mitochondrial
phenotypes and most importantly all the
collaborators who provide
different patient samples and inputs we
conduct this process
including freddie the patios camilla
petrol jet watch taha and also
our collaborators who provide uh new
information about the metabolic
regulation
uh sarah from vib kv reuben
and also the funding support without
their support is not possible to conduct
this research
in a tiny manner and i will be happy to
answer your questions
thank you ping chay that was a great
talk so
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar
and if you have a question you'd like to
ask then please submit it
uh we'll get through as many uh
questions as we can before the end of
the hour
uh and even if we don't make it to your
questions we'll be forwarding them on to
our speaker
and the greater agilent team to follow
up with you so
let's take a look at our questions that
we've got coming
in
so let me see
uh here we go so
have you any information about head and
neck cancers were t-reg populations
shows positive prognosis is there
anything that you could mention on that
one bj
so you know it's difficult to say you
know how people
did this virtual perspective analysis
but i would say that
in the tumor if you see higher t-rex
sometimes you indicate two things one is
that the microbiota is more
immunosuppressive the other one is that
lesser ongoing inflammatory response
that's why you start to see higher red
high-level feedbacks
so i think the positive positive
prognosis
in head neck cancer may be the later
case
probably there are some infiltration of
cdl t cell which can induce uh
environmental response in the human
microenvironment that's why you start to
see something like that try to
show up and then try to compromise this
ongoing anti-tumor response that's why
you see the
positive correlation but i think this
will relies on a lot of
further analysis and one thing we also
need to be careful which we learned from
the calling point is that
actually in colon cancer the
initially people also believe that
there's a positive correlation between
the t-reg abundance and also the
survival
but this is basically um done by the fox
peaceful expression but we have to
realize that in humans
in human t-cells when they get
activation they also start to express
flux p3
in the early observation so the foxp3
expression doesn't mean
they are t-rex you need to use other
markers that's why on simon sakakuchi
they
they did this uh analysis beautifully in
the nature medicine paper they showed
that
you need to see those activated t-rex if
you use the activated t-rex signature
you will start to see that this
signature negatively
associated with the prognosis in colon
cancer patients so this will redefine
how we
think about this biomarker okay great
um another question here is uh
specifically towards cd36 is that also
expressed in cd4 and cd8 t-cells as well
as
t-rex cd4 we are not really
sure uh i don't remember if we checked
the non-t-rex cd4
it must be in our standing panel but i
didn't check that one
but in cds we know that they will also
express cd statistics
and this this includes may do something
uh to hamper cdt's activity
okay here's one i mean you were looking
at uh that kind of goes to more
mitochondrial uh
number and fitness did you also measure
at all
um functional activity
of those mitochondria using uh okay car
readouts at all
that's a great question so we did this
one uh so actually
if those uh those t-rex they don't
express cds or d6 they started
mitochondria
problems you as you as you can see in my
en data
so actually they also drop they also
reduce their old car they start to
increase their econ so
our our theory is that if they have the
mitochondrial problem they will start to
use glucose
more efficiently than the wild type mice
a wild type t-rex
in this case it can be good and also can
be bad
and good for them is that they probably
will engage strongest oppressive
activity but it's not
it's not what we observe however
they probably also have these can use
this approach to suppress the
the immune immune response especially
cjt so by depriving the glucose level
uh in the micro environment but the best
thing is that actually dura microamine
is already glucose deprived so i don't
know whether
this kind of switch will be good for
direct
my my imagination is that they will try
to survive but actually
for the long run this might not be good
because they probably still will
encounter the same problem cdt
encounter they don't get sufficient
glucose
to support your survival and function
do you have any indication of how
quickly that switch
kind of occurs from going from a
t-reg and the pbmc population into i
mean is there any
i i have no idea how quickly this can
happen so i think it might take some
time because initially you probably
still have sufficient lipids to activate
your ppr beta
but you need to have a other pathway
they
um to degrade those ligand or consume
those lichens so i would say i would
imagine that this would take a while but
how long i don't know okay
um what we got here so we have uh
the cd36 knockout have an effect on cp39
expression
that's a good question we didn't check
but we checked the expression of
suppressive markers in cd-36 knockout
and t-rex so
in addition to the t-cell transfer
colitis we also prefer
in vitro i should say ex-vivo
suppressive activity for t-cell
proliferation
so the splenic t-rex from wild type and
knockout they have similar ability to
suppress teaser proliferation
however intra-tumor t-rex if they don't
have cd36
they reduce the suppressive activity and
we don't know whether this is due to
cd39 expression
at least we know that they start to
express a lower level of ketone
exporting
at least we know these two
thank you so uh
somebody would like to ask that in
tissues like adipose tissue
and liver uh cd4 and cd8
t cells overexpress cd36
so does targeting cd36 impatient can it
also affect their function
so it's possible based upon the for
example adipose tissue we probably know
that the
adipose tissue t-rex also expressed cd36
um but whether this cd36 expression do
something for those t-racking adipose
tissue
is not clear because um the knockout
mice doesn't really show any phenotype
and i didn't see any
strong phenotype has been reported
before
and so i'm not really sure but in terms
of safety of this targeting approach i
think
it can be we can consider it might be
quite safe because
in human especially in asian and also
african one in
one thousand people they uh
you will see a cd36 deficiency and they
are viable which is very similar to the
mouse
the only problem is that when you do
blood transfusion they will have some
issues for the
um for the after the trend after the
blood transfusion
but i think overall knee 36 looks like
they they have
they can be a pretty safe target because
then the whole body deficient is
patient you can see
okay next question uh have you seen any
functional difference in terms of
suppressive activity between cd36
positive and negative t-rex
suppressive activity right yes
so as i said in
the tumor infiltrating t-rex we see it
we see the different suppressor
activity um but the the reduction is
is not as strong as uh other
uh systemic t-rex fish are for example
fast p3 deficiency or
you or cko for knockout so
we see something but it's not i think
it's not a major
it's not a major effect of cd certified
deficiency
which can lead to stronger energy
response i think this the survival of
t-rex might be the major issue
rather than a suppressive activity
decline okay
um
how about this so uh would epigenetic
epigenetic modification
on pdc d1 gene coding for pd1
affect checkpoint therapy in any way if
you can see that one yourself
okay so i think that that that's
possible especially you know it has been
shown by
other people like john wary ben
youngblood
and also in general rao that you know
the t-cell exhaustion actually linked
with epigenetic modification
and actually they will help the they
will sustain the pd1 expression in the
fully exhausted t cells and this is
quite important for for their
responsiveness to be 1k
okay thank you
um another question here so are cd38
positives cd8 t
cells but they also use fatty acid
oxidation to generate energy
uh for cydia i'm not really sure
but i don't know if they can do that
because
you know if you consider if you see this
36 expression in cd it may help them to
get the lipid
but the problem is that getting lipid
doesn't doesn't means you can burn lipid
so if you want early lipids you need to
have good mitochondria
and in the tumor micro in one day one
another issue we also need to consider
is hypoxia the hypoxia condition may
may block those t-cells ability to earn
fat so i'm not really sure whether those
t-cells
can really utilize those fatty acids
they
get from cd36 that efficient
okay and kind of a follow-up to the
online so does targeting lipid
metabolism in t-regs
can it also affect cd8 function in tme
as
a acap1 deletion can improve cd8
anti-tumor function
so the eighth one deletion i don't know
this one i think there are some repo
already there
uh i don't remember the details so i'm
going to make the comment on that one
but i think targeting living with
properties and um
in t-rex will affect the cd8 function
we didn't i didn't show the data here
but actually in our original publication
you can see that
if if we compare the cta tiers
between whitehead and also the cd36trx
specific
naka those cd 36 t-rex specific knockout
they have
their cdas teals actually have higher
level of interference gamma and teamwork
production so it looks like targeting
t-rex lipid metabolism will allow the
antimicrobial become less
immunosuppressive
and cgi can exert stronger and happier
response
okay i guess it's the more
general one but considering the changes
in metabolism in cancer
does diabetes also promote cancer
development
would that be fair to assume very
open-ended question it's a pretty open
end so
actually there's some report um i would
say
pretty confusing before but i think both
often
make some sense in certain degree but
i'm my personal impression is that
diabetes will associate with
cancer formation and also poor prognosis
that's pretty
well accepted but whether this will
affect their responsiveness to pd1
blockade
it's hard to say especially based upon
the information we have for neglecting
signaling in the t cells and also the
lipid composition i think this is
something a lot of people they try to
work on
that and try to figure out because based
on ritual perspective analysis you can
see both ends
and there's a paper i remember in nature
medicine also discussed about this
possibility
especially latin signaling
okay more technical question here but
what percentage of tumor condition media
did you use in those experiments
if you use percent actually you will be
quite toxic
so we use 80 so we can still save those
celsius for the for the following
experiment
okay um
this one how do you rule out the other
members
utilizing nad after the nad
supplementation
other members uh in the implementation
we did
in vitro analysis so we give those t-rex
energy in vitro in the presence of
conditional media
so i don't know whether i don't know the
other member means
other immune cells or other enzymes
but in terms of the the essay system i
think it's already quite pure only t-rex
in that system we didn't analyze this
one in vivo
um and i've got one question myself so
um which goes on to the sort of circular
recirculation of nad and
your um complex activity of complex one
with the use of metformin in this case
then which is i think has been used
quite a bit in other
sort of cancer areas would it be
detrimental
in this case fatigue metformin
yeah that's a very interesting question
especially metformin's uh
anti-tumor response is quite it's quite
interesting
so i will still believe metformin can
target intra-tumor t-rex
in certain ways but you know using
metformin in vivo is too dirty because
metformin can also target dendritic cell
macrophage and also cda t
cells okay okay so but if you do the
individual experiment i would i guess
my gut feeling is that you will also see
very similar phenotype as we report here
those t-rex treat with metformin they
might dive and they may lose their
survivability
uh if we culture them in the conditional
medium from cancer cells
okay and again this is
quite an open-ended question i think but
can t-reg cells be used with stem cells
instead to cure cancer
that's a very big question
news with stem cell
i'm not really sure what does this mean
okay well maybe the uh website can put
in some
a follow-up question for us uh
and i think we've got through all the
questions now
we'll just hang on for another five
seconds to see if we get any more
questions in
no problem
okay well there's no more questions so
thank you again
for a great presentation much
appreciated
and thank you for our audience for um
tuning in oh well here we go
one last question did you try this game
in pd1 resistant tumors
so the one we did actually is pd-1
resistance for the v-rapid memory
they don't respond to pd1 and we
did both induced persistent and also in
graftman system
so basically the cd36 treatment alone is
already
elicits better endangerment response
compared with video and basically pd1
doesn't work
but once we combine we see further
further improvement
i think it might be it might indicate
that
if you target t-rex you may have you may
help
those cdit so to become less exhausted
because
only the less exhausted or uh progenitor
exhaustivity so can respond to pd-1
blockade
so i think in the presence of uh
immunosuppressive g recognition of
microbiome can drive
uh the terminal exhaustion so i think
our data also suggests this possibility
okay that's great okay well that's the
end of the questions again thank you
very much pinchay for a great
presentation and thank you again for our
audience for tuning in
thank you thanks goodbye